nina langer recently found herself
becoming an overnight local celebrity
she and husband ludwig takaro are now
famous here in the southeast corner of
bavaria for something they did two
thousand kilometers away
they already had a reputation for their
alternative lifestyle and our regulars
at the local spirituality center
as for involvement on the political
front they wanted to be the first
germans to pay back their share of a
loan that greece was forced to give to
its german occupiers during the second
world war
they had the idea after seeing the greek
finance minister getting a dressing down
from his german counterpart on
television for raising the issue
he just said it was completely out of
the question the greek minister sat
there like a schoolboy getting a
reprimand from a teacher i felt ashamed
the berlin government considers the
reparations question to be legally
settled
athens however was demanding 70 billion
euros for that forced loan
doing some maths ludwig sacaro and lina
lange arrived at a figure of 875 euros
per head
they headed for greece to pay their dues
naf pleo is a major tourist destination
in southern greece
in the 19th century it was the temporary
residence of otto the bavarian-born
first king of modern greece
modern bavarians sakura and langer
likewise came to local fame after
handing over their share of the loan to
a charity serving the needy
while naflio has not been hit as hard by
the greek financial crisis as other
towns in the country the german couple's
gesture was much appreciated
to be honest i couldn't really believe
it at first
but when we read their manifesto we were
very touched
they are convinced that instead of us
owing the germans
it's the germans being in debt to us
this little farm just outside naf pleo
is home to janis and golfo stavropoulos
the retired couple are not interested in
reparations from the germans what they
suffer during the second world war they
say cannot be compensated for with money
i was tending the sheep together with my
brother
then the germans turned up
we were young and carefree
they took my brother and poked him
around with their guns
a shot went off and killed him
the germans haven't changed much
then they came with guns
today with their mighty economy
the nafplio authorities are eager for
peace with germans who comprise the
biggest group among tourists
and after welcoming the bavarians
couples act the mayor firmly believes
they are far from the exception
it was positive for the german's image
that symbolic gesture allowed greeks to
see that the headlines in certain
newspapers in germany
did not reflect the opinions of the
entire german
people although now we don't need any
more germans coming here to settle their
wartime debts
and given that the mayor's office
covered all the couples hotel and
restaurant bills the town has certainly
made no financial profit
the visitors themselves have come away
with a good feeling
afterwards it felt like having gained a
new family of 11 million people
they want to persuade other germans to
similar acts of reconciliation ludwig
has a background in alternative
psychological therapy and wants to
introduce a spiritual edge
i would like to dedicate the circle and
our thoughts to the people of greece and
to the government there
and also to the german government
fight where he and his wife live some
locals are not impressed
a frequently heard opinion is that the
greeks are just after money to pay their
current debts
if i had debts like that i doubt anyone
would give me any more money either
isn't that a good example
the couple's home now boasts a range of
official thanks from their trip
the biggest honor came from crete
the mayor of viano's heard about what we
did and decided to make us honorary
citizens
the couple are planning to return to
greece in the autumn
this time they'll have no reparations
checks with them but the thought remains
the same promoting reconciliation
between greeks and germans